hello everyone it's great to meet you
all today
i'm mohit and i have a phd in
computational biology
and specialization in molecular modeling
simulations and discovery related
research projects
so in today's session
uh in a few slides
i'll go through the publicly available
data recent structural data from the
pandemic
so talking about that the structural
biology response to the clovin 1910
to the kovit 19 panda pink has allowed
the world to see the virus how i mean
the virus is attacking us in us in a
structural uh
perspective so we can visualize we can
see the structure so it has also aided
in vaccine and therapeutic development
has and has shown four sides in the
investments in structural biology
capabilities in you know techniques such
as
as exotic crystallography or techniques
such as cryo-em or the mx
so this sheer magnitude and uniqueness
of the event
that has you know uh
um that has enabled all of us in a way
that
that helped in all these different types
of data that has come out uh from
different repositories so today we we
are going to get an overview of where
this data is and how it looks
so the speed with which these structural
inves investigations have occurred has
been really breathtaking similar
simultaneously the availability of these
data have
has benefited from the long history of
making you know these depositories and
the metadata that is also available uh
with this information about the
structural information and all of this
is available in repositories such as
protein data bank
a worldwide repository for
macromolecular structures and also we
are going to talk about some other
aspects of getting structure which is
through molecular modeling so as the one
and there is like this one and a half
year since the declaration uh of kovite
19 and uh recently 1000 structures of
starscope 2 biomolecules have been
deposited in the pdp itself so these are
all experimental structures that have
been deposited in protein data bank
so it is like kind of you know rare to
obtain a snapshot of such immense effort
in structural biology
and this happened due to this revolution
of not only uh
uh not only the
need or the structures but also the
technology so with cryo-em there's there
has been a lot of you know insights that
we got from the
resolution revolution that is what it is
said in aspect of cryo-em microscopy
uh so uh talking about the computational
aspect of this so first the experimental
aspect is about the structural biology
events
and experiments that led to the
information of this kind of data that
how how these structures are but still
there are many limitations when we are
talking about the complete understanding
of how
it relates how structure can be related
to the function so there are uh that's
where i mean computational structural
biology a computational structural
bioinformatics comes in so where we are
talking about you know modeling complex
structures to gain insight or to be able
to understand the effect of mutations on
these experimental structures so those
things can be modeled and have been
playing a very important role in
understanding the pandemic more and more
and to find solutions so the source of
pandemic as i said uh
has contributed a lot in terms of also
structural biology work so insulin
infrastructure biology work so initially
initially what people were used to do is
i will tell you about some of the
software's that that are available
online tools such as the one that is
listed here
alpha 4
but also there is a software uh that
many of us use for structural
predictions is a ci tesser so from zen's
lab so it's it's an online
online available to
and also alpha fault from deepmind
consortium
they have been able to
with these two rules we have been able
to leverage the uh gene relays release
genomes determine protein sequence and
also to create computational models
and this has been happening till the
early march 2020 to till date so some
modeling uh
a lot of insights that we could draw
from structural data is why i modeling
so how do we model complex structures
how do you model uh single point
mutations or multiple mutations and
understand the variance
and also uh then there is an aspect of
molecular dynamic simulations that have
massively also extended the utility of
experimental structural data that helps
in providing insights while the rapid
analysis of you know these in silico
mutagenesis for many key viral proteins
and also to the ability to for example
model glycosyl glycosylation of the
spike protein
our computational approach has also
helped in probing uh you know host
pathogen protein interactions so protein
protein interaction and then
contributing also in network network
based and machine learning uh based
analysis and we have an upcoming talk
about the network analysis
tomorrow that uh i would
like
you to all know about cyanx club so we
will be sharing that information also
with you
so about the structures and to
understand like what is available out
there and how to understand and make use
of this so that is an important aspect
of integrating structural biology into
your research or you know utilizing the
data that is available publicly so the
spike protein of this virus i mean uh
suspo
is one of the central figure right in
this fight
since it is the primary target for
antibodies uh to provide uh and to
target of antibodies that provide
immunity against the virus so the
surface of corona virus says i'll give
you a
layman explanation so the surface of
corona viruses are covered with these
spikes giving them their distinctive
clown-like appearances in the electron
micrographs so many people are already
aware of this and i think most of us are
so the spikes
the spikes initiate the process of
infection binding to the receptor and
then fusing with the cell membrane to
release the viral genome inside that's
the process so many other and has been
seen in many other models as well like
um
influenza hematoglutinin and also hiv
and ebola so the spike protein is
composed you know of three identical
chains that form together a complex with
a small domain inside uh which is the
which is inside the virus which is the
membrane spinning segment and there is a
there's a large ectodomain
and uh that all you can see some of
those structures that you can see in
this in this uh slide so this structures
also include a portion of
the mini sugar chain that coats the
spike since the sugars are highly
flexible and difficult to observe that's
one of the challenge so many things that
you can gain inside from is are the
structures
are from the structures
and it will tell you more about that so
recent structures have revealed that the
spike of sasco 2 and sasco uh suscov and
saskov 2 so comparing both when you we
compare both we we found out that they
are quite flexible so in these
structures the receptor receptor binding
domains uh the receptor binding domain
are seen in the
in different conformation so when you
compare structures and when you're
superimposing them on one one another in
a three-dimensional space you can see
the differences and how there is a
movement you can find out about that
movement just from your you know screen
so by doing by learning about these
different tools that we will be covering
in this entire program so often just one
domain in this case of cysco ii so
many times what is happening is that one
domain you would see that there is some
movement and then there are several
other extensions that that you will see
that there are tucked down or uh i mean
there are different type of movements
that have been uh found out in these
different types of confirmation and then
uh researchers what researchers have
hypothesized that the recent star scope
to where variants are virulent because
their receptor binding domains are
particularly flexible so that's one of
the hypothesis
and whereas most spread corona viruses
that cause the common cold are less
less dangerous because they are less
flexible so that's one of the hypothesis
that you can understand by comparing
some of these structures and understand
from the different confirmations
that include uh the binding i mean to
understand this this has to be model so
you have structures from different
confirmations that you obtain from
different protein data banks uh
structures uh which are
deposited online and then you try to
model them into a complex that will give
you a clear insight of how this is done
so these are some of the things that you
need to learn computationally in
computational biology or in silico
computational structural biology so
about the receptor binding
our immune system you know fight backs
right when coronavirus infects us so
that's where the antibodies comes in so
antibodies are what are protein
molecules that play a key role in any
organisms defense against a foreign
molecule called antigen right the first
step in this process is specific complex
formation between an antibody molecule
and a molecule of the antigen
so the structural basis of this antibody
antigen recognition is started to
getting illustrated from these
structures so these structures are
helping us to understand that mechanism
how it works
so the spike is a major target of this
protection right since it is exposed to
the surface of the virus and these three
protein i mean these three protein
structures that you can see on the left
which is 3bgf and 2g hw and 6w4 one and
you can totally search them by their
four digital keyword to uh you just
paste them on your browser to show you
to the link to the uh to their actual
structure that has been deposited in the
pdp so these are pdb ids
um so
these three structures um show that the
antibody can be recognized by spike
protein in many ways so two of these
antibodies block the receptor binding
portion of the domain but the other
antibody targets a cryptic site at the
base of the domain that is only exposed
when the antibody binds to it so you see
that there are not only just different
conformation but different active sites
also that you can find
that you can see which depends on the
movement of the protein so one thing
that you have to understand is that this
is a pdp is just a snapshot and
when a protein is in motion then it is
moving so there are different
conformations that are protein attends
and then based on those different
confirmation there could be different
strategies to design molecule so this is
something that we should consider
this sort of structural information is
something that we should consider when
we go about you know
designing a vaccine or when we are
looking for strategies to find out
solutions
to uh you know finding drug finding a
drug
so uh about this uh doing all of this is
kind of possible so in this program we
will be learning to use powerful
visualization tools such as chimera
and explore through the
available structural data
and then also we will you we will be
reviewing
several tools developed for your
training in this program
uh to navigate large data sets and then
connect the various aspects of you know
various aspects of sequence structure
and meta data
into a single experience this is speak
nav
so what it will help us is that it will
help us in understanding or addressing
many questions
so genomic data analysis can be utilized
to see the changes between viral strains
so you're looking at the mutations and
different significance level of these
detector changes and how you track them
or map them to the 3d
position of the on the protein structure
so that you can see whether they are on
the surface whether they are in the
active site what could be the role
then we will be used we will be able to
do you know from sequence to structure
uh another aspect is to do comparison
and that comparison at a sequence level
is could be done through multiple
sequence alignment so multiple sequence
alignment is a very powerful tool to
understand viral adaptation between
animals and protein and again then trace
it back to the structure
similarly another aspect of answering
some of the research questions
would be to understand the relationship
between virus viral and host pro host
proteins such as uh the trimeric sas
corona virus surface surface spike
glycol glycoprotein
so this spike glycoprotein
binds to a cellular receptor called
angiotensin converting enzyme to so ace2
i mean you might have like you might all
i've heard about is 2 in short so and it
mediates through the fusion of viral and
cellular membranes through a pre to post
fusion conformation translation
transitions so as i was telling you
before also so because of certain
binding there are trans uh you know
there are conformational changes that
enables another binding event so all of
this fascinating stuff and
you and and just imagine to be able to
visualize it and to understand from
sequence level to a structural level is
something that we are planning for this
uh program and
we are hoping that many of you can go
through that experience and understand
different aspects of how structure and
complexes uh that mapping mutations
from a single protein from a population
to the three-dimensional structure and
understanding the function obviously is
something that we're trying to
help
everyone to learn
so this is what we have planned for the
structural part and that's what i wanted
to tell you all about in today's session